بلجيكا تفرض عقوباتها على المستوطنين
الاردن ينفذ عمليه انزال جوي في القطاع
للمره الرابعه وواشنطن تؤكد الجدول الزمني
لحرب القطاع طائره الولايات المتحده تحلق
فوق القطاع مجددا تهديد عبري شديد اللهجه
للعاصمه اللبنانيه والرئيس الامريكي يحدد
الوجهه التاليه للجيش الروسي بعد اوكرانيا
والجيش الامريكي يستعد للتدخل موسكو تصرح
ينبغي ل الولايات المتحده ان تختبر قوه
روسيا النوويه وفرنسا لقد حان ترك اللحاق
بامريكا كالكلاب
الامم المتحده
تتحرك غضب تلبيب يبلغ اشده والامم المتحده
هي الهدف ليصرح وزير الخارجيه العبري ايي
كوهان ان ولايه امين عام الامم المتحده
انطونيو وترش تهديد للسلم العالمي جاء بعد
ذلك ارساله خطابا لمجلس الامن حول غزه
لتفعيل الماده ال99 من ميثاق المنظمه وهي
المره الاولى التي يفعل جوتش هذه الماده
لدق ناقوس الخطر بشان غزه اعتمد جوت راش
الماده 99 من الميثاق التاسيسي للامم
المتحده التي نادرا ما تستخدم والتي تخوله
للفت انتباه مجلس الامن الى اي مساله يرى
انها قد تهدد حمايه السلم والامن الدوليين
هناك اكد الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط تاييده بقوه
مبادره الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو وتريش بشان القطاع ليعرب رئيس
الوزراء الاسباني بيدرو سانشيز عن دعمه
الكامل لرساله انطونيو وتريش هذا وتدور
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الفصائل والقوات
العبريه في مدينه خان يونس جنوبي القطاع
واكد الجيش العبري وصوله لوسط خان يونس
وذلك للمره الاولى منذ بدء العمليه البريه
جنوب القطاع فيما قالت هيئه البث العبريه
ان نحو 100 جندي عبري اصيبوا اصابات بالغه
الخطوره في اعينهم خلال المعارك في القطاع
وان 15% منهم اصيبوا بعما جزئي او كامل
هنا اعلن الناطق باسم الفصائل ابو عبيده
عن تدمير
135 اليه عسكريه عبريه كليا او جزئيا في
كافه محاور القتال في القطاع خلال 72 ساعه
من جهه اخرى نقلت وكاله رايترز عن جيك
سيلوفان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
الولايات المتحده ناقش مع تل ابيب جدولها
الزمني للعملي العسكريه في القطاع واضاف
المسؤول ان تل ابيب ارسلت بالفعل موقع
عمليتها البريه فيما اكد مسؤولون امريكيون
بان وزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن قال
لمسؤولين في حكومه الحرب العبريه ان اداره
بايدن تعتقد ان الصراع يجب ان ينتهي خلال
اسابيع لا اشهر واضاف المسؤولون ان هناك
ادراكا من الجميع بانه كلما طال امد هذه
الحرب اصبحت اصعب على الكل وفقا لصحيفه و
ستريت جورنال على ذات السياق قال المتحدث
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر
ان واشنطن لن تقبل اي حديث عن تقليص في
مساحه القطاع بعد انتهاء الحرب واكد ان
الولايات المتحده تعارض اقامه اي مناطق
عزله مقترحه داخل القطاع في بلجيكا قال
رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي الكسندر ديكرو ان
بلاده ستمنع دخول المستوطنين المتطرفين
العبريين اليها وانها ستعمل مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي لفرض ذلك وبعوده للاوضاع في
القطاع نفذت القوات المسلحه الاردنيه
عمليه انزال جوي رابعه لمساعدات اغاثه
عاجله بواسطه مظله للمستشفى الميداني
الاردني في خانيونس جنوب القطاع وتمكنت من
انزال الصناديق التي تحوي مساعدات طبيه
وعلاجيه لاستمراريه ديمومه عمل المستشفى
في ظل الحرب على القطاع فيما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده
استانفت تحليق طائره بدون طيار فوق القطاع
للمساعده في البحث عن الرهائن الذين
تحتجزهم الفصائل اما في تل ابيب فهدد
النتنياهو مقاومه لبنان بانه حال اختار
الحرب الشامله فسوف يحول بيروت الى قطاع
جديد بايدن يحذر
النيتو بعد جمود كبير في امور المساعدات
حدثت انفراجه بسيطه هنا اعلنت الولايات
المتحده تخصيص حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 175 مليون دولار ولكنها
حذرت من انها قد تكون واحده من اخر الحزام
اذا لم يوافق الكونجرس على استمرار
التمويل من جانب اخر ادعى الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن انه واثق من روسيا ستقوم بمهاجمه
دول في حلف الناتو وذلك بعد اعلان موسكو
الانتصار في اوكرانيا فيما اعلن البيت
الابيض ان واشنطن تعتبر مشاركه القوات
الامريكيه في مواجهه مع الجيش الروسي بعد
انتصار روسيا في اوكرانيا امرا مرجحا
للغايه وقال مسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في البيت الابيض جون كاربي انه من المرجح
للغايه ان يتدخل الجيش الامريكي اذا حقق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين نصرا
استراتيجيا في اوكرانيا في فرنسا صرح زعيم
حزب الوطنيين فلوريان فليبو ان الوقت قد
حن لاوروبا للتوقف عن اللحاق بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل اعمى والبدء في
دفع اوكرانيا لابرام معاهده سلام مع روسيا
وتابع اما ان نتبع مثل الكلاب وندمر
انفسنا بلا مقابل او نوقف كل شيء وندفع من
اجل عمليه السلام من الواضح انه يتعين
عليك اختيار هذا الخيار الثاني على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه صرح ضابط الاستخبارات
الامريكي السابق سكوت ريتر بان الجيش
الروسي يستول على زمام المبادره والحق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بالقوات الاوكرانيه وقال
ريتر لقد انتهى الهجوم المضاد الذي شنته
القوات الاوكرانيه واصبح هذا بمثابه هزيمه
استراتيجيه لاوكرانيا والغرب الجماعي هذا
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الروسيه دمرت مراكز قياده ثلاثه الويه
اوكرانيه وكبدت نظام كياف خسائر جسيمه في
مناطق متفرقه ضمن نطاق العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه لتعود الوزاره الروسيه وتعلن
الحصيله بتكب الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
815 قتيلا وجريحا واسقاط مقاتله اوكرانيه
و27 مسيره اطلقتها قوات كياف على مختلف
المحاور خلال 24 ساعه اما في موسكو فبين
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي ريابكوف انه
لا ينبغي على الولايات المتحده ان تختبر
قوه روسيا في موضوع التج النوويه فاذا
استانفت الولايات المتحده فان موسكو سترد
بطريقه مماثله ولهذا السبب يجب ان تكون
على استعداد لاي تطور في الاحداث